today we are doing a snack swap
obviously Team Taiwan and I'm reppin
Team USA let me tell you something
America knows how to put some sugar and
some snacks and make them taste good how
many snacks it's better than any
American I believe it honestly I'm
really excited to show you the stuff
that I grew up with some excitement
[Music]
bicyclist introduced they're so good as
you open it you know that you may not be
your toes at the end of the day it's
worth it that is marshmallow and Rice
Krispies you should be much bigger by
the way I don't know if the FDA issued a
warning these suckers are called Sachi
mom Fatima Fatima the concept is the
same a snack that comes in a block form
it's deep fried noodles and then they
bind it together with this delicious
caramel glaze you got me at caramel I
used to have a ton of these as a kid oh
wow there's huge that would you try you
know look at the size of it I think this
is the only time the American portion is
smaller than the international version
you eat a whole one of these you can eat
like five of these oh I love the caramel
if you put powdered sugar on top of this
it would taste like a funnel cake
breakfast lunch and dinner this is a
journey it smells like vanilla ice cream
is really good I don't remember so much
marshmallow flavor it's not as sweet as
I thought it was gonna be this is
getting a little bit too sweet for me
I'm going to just lay this in the teeth
oh yes I forgot to mention it's super
sticky
I would rather dentists visit then oh my
god
oh my gosh looks so similar we have the
color goal which is the pee crackers
made from please yeah they're just
delicious there's one of my favorite sex
everybody knows that everybody has had
it as a pet garlicky flavor is like a
new mommy bomb and little chips u.s.
America we have Fritos flavor twists
honey barbecue I remember so vividly
getting so excited to buy these growing
up we used to do frito pies which we you
see like chili and cheese they're so
good so delicious we hang G barbecue
flavor with that twist and that crunchy
actually taste the flavors five hours
after you go oh it smells good look at
the color difference I could actually
eat this whole back this is very very
salty oh this is like a light delicate
garlic flavor comes in like moments
later it's really salty but I can't stop
eating it I don't know what America has
done to it
just eat rockers now let me switch with
you for a brief pressure I got to give
its nut country man I've got to give it
to my country and Brunswick blubber I
think I'm gonna have to stick with them
this is a lot more flavorful I think I
can I can get chili pilot beef jerky
this is like a childhood staple as well
kind of hometown school having a beef
jerky the snack that you would take like
camping so this is also beef jerky also
my childhood favorite juicy and tender
and it's like all kinds amazing and
Taiwan you'd see stalls and they would
literally be grilling the jerky so you
saw it up close of you saw you know how
your Noah's getting made every time I go
to Taiwan I honestly just want to bring
a suitcase over like pork jerky back but
US Customs won't let me package
I feel like gold is inside of this
laughs open my golden ticket smells like
liquid smoke it's like what you can feed
your family for a week this is one piece
oh it smells so good I feel like this
was pressuring me I go they just sent it
here like an hour ago or so okay wow
that is it not bad color
what now you knows I don't care what
walking around like this you can see
it's like softer yes it's like it's not
moving this texture is a little
artificial I still like this I was like
what I think of when I think of me just
like a lot of salt a lot of a lot of a
lot this actually tastes really good man
America will be doing what are you doing
I know it sounds like I'm not rock with
my country but how can you blame me when
you got textured tender jerky I will
always go with our jerky
I have a pineapple cakes which are our
specialty national treasures Taiwan this
is what we gift friends it's essentially
shortbread on the outside and like a
planet Bowl / winter melon jam on the
inside so good I grew up with these like
every day in my house not free nothin up
and I raised the fat free ones it sounds
very similar outside kind of key key
layer with I love oh oh the smell just
comes out and it's just so rich with
pineapple oh they are almost the same
size this year I really like the fig jam
and the breading they show flavor is a
little more sophisticated but I like it
you know for similar the cake is very
buttery yeah I need a refresher big
choice at home no high fructose corn
syrup so she would see with his jaws
made with real fruit real pineapple
disagree it's a pineapple cake length
yeah I think pineapple cake wins in this
case sorry mr. Nader sorry mr. mutant
sorry not sorry
I owe you good
goldfish weren't really nice saying
cheese it's worth but you know what
as I got older I've actually kind of
like Rome to like this one time I ate a
whole bag of these and then I vomited in
the back of my mom's van then when I was
a kid because I love them I love them so
much this says it's made with smiles oh
I have a squid chips
it says son Yeol way like it just means
very squid flavor which I know sounds
bizarre I've had this a lot as a kid if
you bring us to the supermarket the
grocery store would be like this is the
one just seeing the packaging it's like
very nostalgic oMG the flavor whiplashes
you first and foremost oh my god this is
so cool look at how cute this is
look at how adorable right I'm doing a
little ring action then okay hello I'm
just really intrigued by the concept of
a squid chip there she is
yes really subtle squid flavour witness
is loving this the school is like a dad
welcome to Taiwan the thing that made
you vomit stops better to get quantity
I like the goldfish Oh what it like it's
cheesy I think I didn't like when I was
like because I like my cheddar to hit me
in the face my cheese is like very
subtle I can see myself snacking on this
like just like this complements it so
well
oh the combination I'm gonna give this a
time all right mayor but a fish squid
fight a snack as a snack and I'm the
snack fan I think we need to get our
blood pressure check now Amanda how we
doing he's had like sodium sugar it was
wet yes ready for bed yeah I really
wanted come to Taiwan
let's do it
[Music]